so we reset everyone Peter King to zero
and zero and you have your playoff picks
we didn't we've gleaned some of your
thoughts so far this show I could
probably guess a few of them although
I've all I have to do is look down and
see all of them tell us who you have
let's go one division at a time who are
your four division champions and then
we'll get to the wildcard picks okay NFC
I've got Philadelphia winning the East
Green Bay winning the north edging the
Bears I've got the Saints winning the
south and the Rams winning the West
wild-card teams I've got who do I have
the bear am i drawn of 49ers yeah I got
the Bears number five and I've got San
Francisco number six now here's the one
thing about picking every year and why I
every year when I pick you know the
playoff order and everything everybody
always says oh my god this guy is insane
blah blah that's because you don't pick
up in 2019 where you left off in 2018
right in the last three years there have
been seven seven and six different
playoff teams from one year to the next
so you've got to pick some some picks
that basically make you say are you
kidding me that's right and that's one
of the reasons why I always look for
teams I go on the training camp tour and
I say my god San Francisco if Jimmy
Garoppolo doesn't slip on a banana peel
in September if he plays 15 or 16 games
I really like the 49ers so we'll see I
don't know they don't sell insurance for
this stuff as chris's buddy bill
parcells used to say but i will just say
this about the NFC yeah I think it's
absolutely wide-open I think
Philadelphia could win it I think a team
could get hot and on a roll like San
Francisco and win it but I'm picking New
Orleans because I think entering the
year they have the fewest holes of any
team in the NFC yeah and I tell you what
Peter I agree completely you have to
have that willingness to forget about
last year and understand that there will
be turnover the
oblem is spotting the teams from last
year that aren't gonna get back and the
ones that will and also which of the
non-playoff teams can rise up and saints
and Rams are the two that I know Chris
and I are the most nervous about not
being able to get back that's what stood
out to me that you have so much faith in
both the Saints in the Rams what do you
think about the Rams
what what what carries over that allows
them to fend off the Seahawks at the top
of the NFC West because I think the
Seahawks are gonna be serious serious
contender you know I'm in the playoffs
at all I don't have the Seahawks or
Cowboys in the playoffs and I think both
of them could make the playoffs the
thing I like about the Rams and I wrote
about this a couple of weeks ago is that
Shaun McVeigh realizes now and I used
the sixth play of the Superbowl as a
metaphor where Jared Goff did not choose
to take the deep shot downfield to
Brandon cooks and he would have had him
open and he should have made that throw
but basically McVeigh blames himself for
being too conservative
don't make that big mistake against the
Patriots and I think right now when you
look at the Rams you were going to see
them as a more attacking offensive team
from play one to the end of the year and
I like that Chris what stands out for
you the most from Peters pitch well the
Rams is the bait I was a big one for me
too
because I do look at it and I know what
Peter said I mean I got a see McVeigh
reinvent himself to a degree he's gonna
have to bring another element to that
offense because I do think the NFL
caught on to that formula a little bit
also I look at the Rams and go you know
what did they really do this offseason
to get better you know the old saying
like if you stay the same you're getting
worse in the NFL that's where I worry
about Whitworth is a year older they
lost a star one of their best saw
lineman and Saffold he's gone you know I
do LaMarcus Joyner was good and AMA
consume is good so I worry about the
Rams I'm there with you
I'm interested also and the fact Peters
got Green Bay in the 49ers that's her
gutsy moves cuz I like the team's but I
didn't have the guts to pick him to go
to the playoffs because of just
uncertainty at the quarterback in the OC
situations all right well crap peter has
buttoned up his picks that's the best I
can do in the AFC Peter let's go through
it like we did last time give us your
division
champions for the AFC for the 2019
season and your two wildcard picks and
then will either agree or hopefully
disagree well thank you mr. segue we
will go with in order of seed number one
Kansas City winning the West number two
Pittsburgh winning the north number
three New England winning the East just
because I'm so bored of the Patriots
always being one of the top two seeds I
have no good reason for that whatsoever
and the fourth seed the Indianapolis
Colts winning the south my two wild-card
teams in the AFC five chargers six
Texans and I really really wanted to
pick a crazy team either somebody from
the east let's say I just didn't love
anybody in the East I think that that
Le'Veon Bell is gonna get beat up behind
that offensive line I didn't love
Baltimore enough to pick them even
though that wouldn't have been a shock
and I kind of I toyed with Cleveland and
I would not be surprised if Cleveland
wins ten games but I don't know there's
so much on Cleveland's plate that I
wonder how they'll handle how will they
handle three prime time games in the
first five weeks of the season and
everybody said oh that's a ridiculous
thing it might be ridiculous all I know
is you've got a coach and a quarterback
in every star on the team with the
exception of Odell Beckham who's there
there they haven't played in prime time
virtually at all and now they're going
to be America's darlings how do you cope
with that
so Cleveland probably came the closest
at the end but I ended up giving Houston
my six seed I agree with you on the
Browns how are they gonna deal with
adversity I mean I don't know whether or
not I'm putting them in or out of the
playoffs yet I got to finalize my picks
this morning but I when they have an
unexpected loss if they lose to the
Titans on Sunday which would not shock
me if that occurs Peter because the
Titans are a team that can play up and
down to the level of whatever
competition you put on the field with
them how will they respond Chris how
concerned are you about that adverse
city is gonna happen how will the Browns
deal with it with a head coach who a
year ago we would not have said hey that
Freddie kitchens is destined to be an
NFL head coach no definitely not but
he's certainly proven that he's worthy
of it to this point I mean we haven't
seen too many cracks in the armor I mean
I like the way he controls his football
team the things he says in the media
they got a quarterback more importantly
that is very good at handling
personalities he's old-school Baker
Mayfield he really is he's like a
quarterback from the 70s or 80s I don't
think he's scared to MF players or yell
at the offense or yell at the coaches
anything like that you got a guy like
Steve Wilkes as a defensive coordinator
who's been around the block for a while
and just was a head coach so I think the
right leadership there I I was on the
fence with the Browns too but when I got
into the Nitty Gritty I put them in I
excited I'm squeaking in just barely the
last week of the season but the big
question is certainly all of that can
they deliver you know with the bullseye
on their back and being a young team and
then they're unproven commodity as far
as that conversation goes to this point
Peter what causes you to have more faith
in the Steelers than the Ravens in the
AFC North because I'll tell you the
Ravens defense I think it's still going
to be potent the offense we don't know
what it's going to be because they've
kept it so under wraps but why the
Steelers over the raven if if you told
me right now that earl thomas played 16
games he is the vital edy
reed type piece to the baltimore puzzle
and if he plays 16 games and I think
it's more likely than not he won't but
if he plays 16 games I think Baltimore
absolutely could win 11 win that
division
I just think Pittsburgh has fewer
questions than either of the other two
teams I think Devon Bush in the middle
of their defense is really going to add
a lot and I also think that they're not
going to have the constant tornados
around their head of Antonio Brown or
Le'Veon Bell I think that bodes well for
Pittsburgh
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports